we turn now to former president Donald
Trump's return to the prime time TV
Spotlight and new signs his 2024
re-election campaign will be a lot like
the last two in a CNN Town Hall last
night Trump repeated the lie that the
2020 election was rigged he dodged
questions on abortion mocked his sexual
abuse accuser and celebrated his
supporters who stormed the capital Arbor
Acosta is in Manchester New Hampshire
with more on the Town Hall's potential
impact on the presidential race Bob good
morning
good morning Vlad Trump's allies are
casting this event as a showcase for
Republican voters coming amid his
mounting legal challenges but Democrats
meanwhile are saying that some of
Trump's statements might scare off
independent voters especially his
suggestion that Congress should consider
allowing the nation to default on its
debt
I say to the Republicans out there
Congressman Senators if they don't give
you massive cuts
you're going to have to do a default in
a high stakes Town Hall former president
Donald Trump said Congress should allow
the government to default if it can't
cut a deal with the White House on
spending as a June 1st deadline to raise
the debt sailing looms well you might as
well do it now because you'll do it
later and it could be very bad it could
be maybe nothing and on the Russian
invasion of Ukraine if I'm president I
will have that War settled in one day 24
hours the former president would not
commit to continuing usaid to Ukraine
and would not say if he wants Ukraine to
win the war do you want Ukraine to win
this War uh I don't think in terms of
winning and losing I think in terms of
getting it settled Trump also repeated
his false claims of fraud in the 2020
presidential election Dodge questions on
abortion and defended his actions on
January 6. as well as those who attended
his rally the day the capital was
stormed they were there with love in
their heart that was an unbelievable and
it was a beautiful day prompting
president buy it into post on Twitter
the January 6 rioters were not good
people end of story The Town Hall was
the first time Trump faced questions
since a New York civil jury found him
liable for sexual abuse and defamation
of writer E Gene Carroll whose claims he
repeatedly denied disparaged and mocked
what's happening is they're doing this
for election interference and I swear
and I've never done that and I swear to
I have no idea who the hell she's a
woman and at a New Hampshire Diner the
legal issues facing Trump don't seem to
phase Republican voters like Louise Hoyt
who said she's voting for Trump all
these legal challenges they don't phase
you no because they've come up with them
out of the woodwork from day one the
future of the Republican parties at
stake campaigning to beat Trump for the
GOP nomination former Arkansas governor
Aza Hutchison told CBS News Republicans
will suffer if they back Trump again
what's your assessment of Trump's legal
challenges all of his legal challenges
are distractions from the issues that
impact Americans and that candidates
want to talk about
sources tell CBS news that Trump showed
Rivals and potential Rivals exactly who
he is in this town hall as this
presidential race unfolds and some top
Republicans privately tell us that while
they would like to see Trump stumble in
the coming months they do not expect him
to fade anytime soon Tony
now he has not changed Bob thank you
very much